we are getting an unprecedented look
into how the existence of two popes is
proving little awkward the co-author of
a new book on celibacy that's out today
in France is former Pope Benedict
although Benedict has now asked that his
name be removed the book comes as Pope
Francis weighs a critical decision on
this fundamental issue for all Catholics
Seth Doane is outside the Vatican with
more on this story good morning to you
Seth what's going on here good morning
well here are the plot points of this
Vatican drama you have the issue of
celibacy which of course is central to
the priesthood and then you have two
popes often seen on different sides of
the spectrum one more conservative one
more liberal and of course there is only
one church I do experience the moments
with you in the Hollywood version the
two Pope's find common ground the
real-life version may not be quite as
tidy to have two men at the Vatican
dressed in white is rare to say the
least
Benedict the sixteenth is just the
second pope to resign in the church's
2000 year history as Pope emeritus
Benedict pledged not to interfere on
major church affairs to leave room for
his successor Pope Francis to lead so
that's why when the former Pope was
cited as co-author in a new book which
addresses the issue of celibacy Benedict
was seen as putting a very influential
papal thumb on the scales as Francis
weighs a key decision
Benedict argued for the necessity of
celibacy writing serving the Lord
requires the total gift of a man Francis
who also supports priestly celibacy is
contemplating a rule change recommended
by bishops allowing the ordination of
older married men in remote regions of
the Amazon where there's a priest
shortage of course everybody knew that a
retired Pope is in the church always is
a difficult situation Monsignor Karol
Castile served seven popes and says on
key church issues these two popes are
generally aligned when Pope Benedict
left the papacy he vowed to be quiet
this is not being quiet
he vowed to be obedient to his successor
I I never heard that he would shut up
forever
this created such a mess that Benedict's
personal secretary archbishop Georg and
Swain reached out to the main author of
the book Cardinal Robert Serra asking
him to remove Benedict as co-author
calling it a misunderstanding
adding in a statement that Benedict had
not authorized a joint authorship but
the esteemed Cardinal stands by his
version of events tweeting personal
correspondence with the Pope emeritus
who on his letterhead wrote to the
Cardinal finally I'm able to send you my
thoughts on the priesthood I leave it to
you if you find some usefulness in them
then the retired Pope wrote the text can
be published the Holy Father likes
people to say what they have to say
does he like other Pope's to say what
they have to say that's the question you
have to ask the Holy Father himself now
we are hearing from the US publisher
today that they do plan to go ahead and
publish this book as co-authored and for
a bit of historical reference that first
pope to step down well he was imprisoned
by his successor so Tony for all the
drama today historically speaking it's
not that bad oh man you know if I were a
publisher if I were an author I think
I'd want to have a pope there on the
cover as well that does dry book sales I
imagine oh it's interesting Pope's have
drama too yes there especially when
there are two of them all right thank
you very much we appreciate it
you